hey folks I'm Kurt novena and for
today's very special play for all
interview we are joined with Emily grace
buck who is a narrative designer who's
worked on telltale games like Batman
cards the galaxy and The Walking Dead
Emily thank you for being here it's an
honor you're here Thank You Kurt I'm so
happy to be here today this is great
we're here to talk about the way lenders
a party based narrative driven RPG so
Emily give us give us the rundown
what is the way lenders great so the way
Landers is a tactical RPG set in ancient
Ireland and Spain that follows history
and legends of the Celts a lot of which
many people might not be very familiar
with it is a party based RPG there is
romance there are plenty of fun
conversations with all of party members
there is monsters that you've never seen
before it should be a really great time
I'm really happy to be working on it
because we're showing a slice of history
that most people might not be familiar
with some of the races in the game
include mauryans for mauryans a
different version of werewolves than
most people have seen so it's not your
typical fantasy races out of Tolkien we
don't have any elves we don't have any
dwarves sorry to everybody who likes
elves and dwarf
doing some fun and different stuff with
this one that's fun
also to be noted as we wrote it in a
little bit more of a modern voice so
it's a fantasy epic RPG set in Celtic
time but a lot of the humor it's a
little bit more modern so I hope people
will have fun playing that so you touch
you touch down a lot in that that I'm
curious about first off that's great
it's a relief that we're getting a
different side of fantasy especially in
an RPG and also use the different kinds
of werewolves and I want to come back to
that because I like werewolves don't get
the love that they deserve you've you've
had a past and doing very narrative
focused games games that usually the the
sole mechanic is to push the story along
by your choice
so this in a lot of ways sounds like a
change of pace and one thing I'm curious
about is what that translation that
transition was like moving from a very
narrative focused games to this now kind
of expansive RPG thing you got going
definitely so that was a transition that
I had been wanting to make for some time
and it's probably something that I
should mention that many of the
narrative designers at telltale had
worked on games that weren't just
telltale games in the past and many
mechanics were brought up in a lot of
those telltale games to potentially go
in other than just the narrative
mechanics so even while I was working at
telltale I did a lot of work on things
that maybe didn't make it into the final
games usually for production reasons
like I don't know if I need to go into
the whole story about how things went
down at telltale but um lots of things
went to also I'm somebody who I grew up
playing RPGs like I was a huge Dungeons
& Dragons fan still am tabletop RPGs I
loved baldur's gate games I've played
pretty much everything Bioware has ever
put out so being able to sink my teeth
into something like this has just been
delightful there are definitely extra
challenges beyond something like a
telltale game because obviously the
focus in way Landers is more on combat
and not necessarily on talking to your
party members although that does affect
the story in the gameplay a lot too but
it's been just delightful sinking my
teeth into that and getting to work with
the rest of the team on making
everything coming together so you get to
go back to the roots of things that you
loved in the past which is great
congratulations me to go and I hope yes
you know like and I'm sure that was
sounds like almost like a relief in a
way that you get to kind of go back to
your own personal roots but with your
great storytelling background as well
yeah I would say so definitely it's nice
to be able to have more mechanics at
your disposal
what was that shift like going from
doing stuff like Batman in The Walking
Dead and guardians to now Celtic
mythology fantasy it's definitely a
different type of research so when I was
working on things like Batman and The
Walking Dead you go to the comic source
material you watch the films you play
other games you watch the television
shows you take in as much as you can to
really understand the spirit of the IP
and I'm lucky that many of the IP I got
to work on at telltale I was already a
huge fan of I've been pretty vocal about
having been a you know Batman fan all of
my life but I've also always been really
into European history I actually my
minor in university was Medieval and
Renaissance Studies so in a lot of ways
this felt like a coming home to but the
type of research I'm doing here is you
know reading old Celtic poems and the
part that was the most exciting for me
actually going to ruins in kaliesha
Spain with the team oh yeah there are a
number of levels in the game that are
actual places you can go and visit in
Spain right now they're still there it's
real even the main city Brigante a that
you go to is Karuna where the studio is
based so this wasn't just reading books
to see what work it was talking to
people in the city to learn about their
local myths and legends going and seeing
plaques lights like putting my hands in
the dirt dealing with a rain felt like
because it's super rainy and yeah it was
extremely hands-on research and I hope
that every writer who gets to write
about a culprit they're part of or not a
part of gets to do something like that
in their life
it was just exquisite there was um this
one thing that I got to do with the team
in Kiruna that I'm not completely sure
how we're gonna integrate it into the
game yet but there's a drink and
alcoholic drink in that part of Spain
that's met said to be tied to witch's
magic and there's like a 30-minute long
chant that they do with the bar as
they're making it and then they light it
on fire and
like spoon it out with a ladle as it's
still on fire and pass it out to
everyone in the bar and you know I got
to go do that with everyone and we're
using it as fodder for the game so that
was real on the players I know I was
brilliant as amazing d like I could just
feel like the enthusiasm coming through
and as for that witchcraft drink I would
sit there for 30 minutes in a game and
listen to that listen to that chant and
that that thing happened so that sounds
incredible you mentioned earlier kind of
evoke in evoking modern or modern way of
speaking what is that process like
trying to modernize that language
absolutely so when I first started
writing for this game I used the more
traditional kind of fantasy speak you
know everything sounded like a that kind
of fake high Old English that were used
to hearing because talking did it and
then every other fantasy property
started doing it you know that's what's
in most other modern RPGs but then I
kind of was brought back to some of my
own roots of how I got into working in
video games you know I came up in fan
fiction and so many people who are
really passionate about things like
Bioware games things like bethesda games
they read and write a ton of that type
of material and I don't want to say that
we like Tumblr aside the game because
that's bananas but I want to appeal to
not just hardcore older RPG fans with
the story of the game a lot of the
themes that we're touching on our modern
they're things that still touch people
today like I said even the sets are
things you can still go to today and the
whole theme is about you know connecting
different time periods so I wanted to
make this feel accessible I wanted to
make it feel fresh so that if someone
picked this up and this was their first
RPG ever and they were looking to
romance a werewolf
they'd have a fun time and it would be
closer to something they might hear on
TV
it took some iterations to get it right
and I think there are still some edits I
want to make to kind of work on that
voice but it's been a fun challenge and
I hope people enjoy it some of the the
key things you've mentioned that really
stand out to me is that it is it is a is
high fantasy from what it sounds like
but still rooted in ingenuine mythology
in history but you're also trying to
stray away from fantasy clichés or the
fantasy tropes we're all familiar with
because the tolki and and all that jazz
while doing this kind of this modern
twist in it so it sounds like a like a
telling commitment of trying to change
or at least just trying to create
something genuinely new so there's just
a lot of moving parts and systems there
that I find amazing and also how do you
romance a werewolf I guess you'll find
out so the werewolves at the same
because you said something about
werewolves earlier they're a little
different than the traditional
werewolves that you see because they're
based more out of Celtic mythology
instead of humans who you know turn into
a wolf under the full moon and lose all
their ability to do anything but hunt
like you see a lot of the time these
werewolves are wearable all of the time
they are born a werewolf they will die a
werewolf they're descendants of the
Great Wolf God Luke who actually is
someone you meet in our game very early
on within the first hour or so and some
of them are just
wolves who have the intelligence of
humans and you have a party member who
is on that side of the spectrum and then
others are almost entirely human looking
who have some of the skill and tricks of
wolves and you can play as one of those
kinds of werewolves they live in camps
outside the city you get to visit camp a
cool I like I'm super yeah also and it
was there I know you've mentioned for
some reason like I don't know why I'm so
fixed ya know her laugh part of it you
mentioned there weren't elves is there
any other standout maybe not typical
fantasy trope class that you're really
excited about that's in this game there
are three actually so the first one
would be the trash nose or the goblins
goblins nose that's good right trash
they are small creatures who like to
play pranks on people they don't speak
they like make jingling music noises and
they just basically mess with people to
entertain themselves and you eventually
get one as a party member in our game
there's also the femoral who are giant
cannibalistic cyclopses so that's fun
there's one of them in your party and
you'll need a bunch of them they live
underground in a very cramped place full
of lava and perpetual screaming and eat
each other because that's all they have
can I like get all yes sweet I'm gonna
go and get a wish craft drink have them
serenade me for 30 minutes and then I'm
gonna go and find my candle cyclops pal
and hang out with the trash nose in a
werewolf I think you're starting to get
this game
I think I think it's I'm starting to
like already feel it so okay that's
perfect the last of our specialty races
would be the mauryans and they're also
based off of Celtic lore we didn't
invent any of these these all came out
of you know the myths and legends in
history the mauryans live underground
they have bold eyes and they're immortal
they also tend to trend towards being
magic users and they have their entirely
separate society from what's going on on
the surface so this might sound a little
bit like dwarfs but they're they're not
short they tend to be tall and darker
skin and elegant and extremely rich
they're they're cool you get to meet one
of them in the first scene is Asia who's
one of the main characters in the game
that's incredible so something else I
wanted to touch on is the idea of this
the span and time and kind of how that
works or what that concept is if you
could explain to me like I understand
like is it a thousand it's like a
thousand years between these things or
how does the time work in this game yeah
it's around a thousand years so the idea
is very early on in the game something
happens to your character I won't go
into a ton of detail because I don't
want to spoil everything and all this
some of those cutscenes aren't in the
game yet we are an early access it's not
finished
some of the story is not going to make
total sense yet something happens to
your character where you get
disconnected from time and this is
relatively important because there are
people including that character I
mentioned in Isaiah who are supposed to
be able to see throughout time people
can see the future and see the past but
you don't exist in the timeline anymore
which means you can mess with it so you
can time jump between Celtic times and
medieval times in order to try and solve
some of
the overall mysteries that are going on
in the game and this provides us a way
to look a lot at what was happening in
European culture at the time a lot
changed in Spain between you know the
Year Zero and like 1300 ad a lot changed
like when this game starts out there's
no Christianity anywhere in Europe yet
but of course when you do the time jump
you're in full-on Catholic Spain so
things were really really different but
we're running with the idea that the
Celtic world was real because this is
based off the myths and legends so some
of your party members are immortal which
means when you time skip more than a
thousand years into the future they're
still bigger they'll be there and some
of your other party members reincarnate
so when you time-skip they're not there
but their soul is and it's in somebody
else so how do you find them to get them
to help you on your journey this is a
lot and it like in a good way like it
sounds like no it's not it's like it's
very easy like I'm excited over the
ideas of it is this something like a
player could is it time jumping
something required for a player can we
go through time as is or is this
something we're put into a position I
have to do the progress in certain place
you're going to need to time jump in
order to progress in certain ways in
order to like solve the main plotline
you have to spend time in both eras the
first act is entirely in the Celtic era
that can act is when you start to open
up the medieval as well got it well
highly encourage people to go back worth
because I want them to see everything
cool that we put in this game but also
they're gonna have to yeah that's the
nature I love that idea
the and going off and speaking in early
access what is that like for you as
someone who's heavily - you know pushing
the narrative and story of this game
and putting in the hands to help you
kind of develop that was that so is this
something you had to do in the past and
how does this differ from maybe ideas
you had that are may change because of
early access I don't know how that works
this is the first time I've worked on an
early access title so that's a little
bit new and different for me but at the
same time when I worked at telltale we
released the episodes one at a time when
we released episode 1 for example that
was usually around the time that episode
4 was just starting production so if
there was response to the earlier
episodes we could course practice later
once or listen to what people were doing
what they liked what they didn't like
any choices that had you know 90% of
people going one way maybe those weren't
the best ones to base later things in
the games off of because you know he'd
be making content for only 10% of people
which is a really expensive decision so
that is not super new to me the main
part of early access that has been a
transition has been like I mentioned
we're missing cutscenes and a lot of
places so there are parts of the story
that just don't make sense right now and
people are like wow the story doesn't
make sense and I'm like you are correct
that is accurate I'm so sorry but it's
nice to know I can fix it it's not just
out there and it's a known shippable
that's you know done it there's time to
iterate on the game and listen to
feedback and make changes if things
really aren't working and that is so
valuable this sounds great I have I want
to go romance a trash knows I want to go
time jump I want to find people who are
recording themselves or being recorded
in two different bodies over time it's
overall just sounds like a relief to
hear an RPG fantasy that's trying to at
least pivot in different directions so
Emily can't wait for it I'm very excited
about it
but unfortunately that's all the time we
have for today so this is that moment in
which you get to tell us we already know
it's an early access but where can we
get it what can we expect and is there a
time in the future
that we can maybe think of time jumping
to in which the game will be officially
out absolutely so right now the game is
exclusively on Steam as an early access
title please go buy it or add it to your
wishlist consider taking a look at it we
just dropped a new patch that includes a
dungeon you can play endlessly the other
day so that's fun we don't have a
timeline for exactly when the full game
is going to be out yet but we are adding
patches regularly with new content and
bug fixes so it's improving rapidly and
stay tuned to for one will know the full
release fantastic well Thank You Emily
for your time Shirley it's been an honor
and for everything weigh Landers you
know everything coming up stay here at
GameSpot thanks folks
[Music]